This lecture is about the basic
measures for evaluation of text
retrieval systems.
In this lecture we're going to discuss
how we design basic measures.
To quantitatively compared to retrieval
systems.
This is a slide that you have seen
earlier in the lecture where we talked about.
Cranfield evaluation methodology. We can have a test collection that
consists of queries, documents and
relevance judgments.
We can then run two systems on these
datasets to quantitatively evaluate
their performance.
And we raised the question about which
set of results is better. Is system a
better or system B better?
So let's now talk about how to actually
quantify their performance.
Suppose we have a total of 10 relevant
documents in the collection for this
query.
Now the relevance judgments shown on
the right.
Did not include all the ten, obviously
and we have only seen three relevant
documents there, but we can imagine
there are other relevant documents in
judge before this query.
So now intuitively we thought that
system A is better because it did not
have much noise, and in particular we
have seen that among the three results,
two of them are relevant.
But in system B.
We have 5 results and only three of
them are relevant.
So intuitively it looks like system A is
more accurate and this intuition can be
captured by a measure called precision
where we simply compute: to what
extent,
all the retrieval results are relevant
if you have 100% precision, that would
mean all the retrieval documents are
relevant.
So in this case the system A has a
precision of two out of three, system B
has 3 / 5.
And this shows that system A is better
by precision.
But we also talked about System B might
be preferred by some other users who
like to retrieve as many relevant
documents as possible.
So in that case will have to compare
the number of relevant documents, then
retrieve and there is another measure
called recall.
This measures the completeness of
coverage of relevant documents in your
retrieval.
Result, so we just assume that there
are 10 relevant documents in the
collection.
An here we've got two of them in system
A, so the record is 2 out of 10 Whereas
System B has got three.
So it's a 3 out of 10.
Now we can see by recall system B is
better and these two measures turn out
to be the very basic measures for
evaluating search engines, and they are
very important because they also widely
used in.
Many other task evaluation problems,
for example, if you look at the
applications of machine learning, you
tend to see precision recall numbers
being reported for all kinds of tasks.
OK, so now let's define these two
measures more precisely, and these
measures are to evaluate a set of
retrieval documents.
So that means we are considering that
approximation of the set of relevant
documents.
We can distinguish it into 4 cases depending
on the situation of the document.
A document that can be retrieved or not
retrieved, right?
Because we're talking about the set of
results.
A document can be also relevant or non
relevant depending on whether the user
thinks this is useful document.
So we can now have counts of documents
in each of the four categories.
We can have A to represent the number
of documents that are retrieved and
relevant.
B for documents that are not retrieved
but relevant, etc.
Now with this table, then we could
define precision as the.
Ratio of.
The relevant retrieved documents A to
the total number of retrieval
documents, so this is just A divided by
the sum of A&C.
sum of this column.
Similarly, recall is defined by dividing A
by the sum of A&B, so that's again the
divide A by the sum of the rule instead
of the column.
Right, so we can see precision and
recall is all focused on looking at A.
That's the number of retrieval relevant
documents.
But we're going to use different
denominators.
OK, So what would be an ideal result?
You can easily see in the ideal case we
have precision and recall, or to be 1.0
that means we have got 1% of all the
relevant documents in our results and
all the results that we return are
relevant.
At least there's no single nonrelevant
document in return.
In reality, however, high record tends
to be associated with low precision.
And you can imagine why that's the case
as you go down the list to try to get
as many relevant documents as possible,
you tend to encounter a lot of non
relevant documents, so the precision
would go down.
Note that this set can also be defined
by a cut off in the ranked list.
That's why although these two measures
are defined for a set of retrieval
documents, they are actually very
useful for evaluating a ranked list.
There are fundamental measures in text
retrieval and many other tasks.
We often are interested in the
precision at 10 documents for web
search.
This means we look at the how many
documents among the top 10 results are
actually relevant.
Now this is a very meaningful measure
because it tells us how many relevant
documents the
User can expect to see on the first
page of search results where they
typically show 10 results.
So precision and recall are the basic
measures and we need to use them to
further evaluate search engine.
But there are the
building blocks really.
We just said that there tends to be a
tradeoff between precision and recall,
so naturally it would be interesting to
combine them.
And here's one measure that's often
used called F measure.
And, it's a harmonic mean of precision and
recall is defined on this slide.
So you can see.
It first.
Compute the.
Inverse of R and P here and then it would
interpret the two by using the
coefficients.
Depending on a parameter beta.
And after some transformation you can
easily see it would be of this form.
And in any case, this is just a
combination of precision and recall.
Beta is a parameter that's often set to
one.
It can control the emphasis on
precision or recall when we set Beta
to one, we end up having a special case
of F measure, often called F1.
This is a popular measure that's often
used little combine precision and
recall, and formula looks very simple.
It's just this here.
Now it's easy to see that if you have a
larger precision or larger recall than
F measure would be high.
But what's interesting is that.
The tradeoff between precision and
recall is captured in the interesting
way in F1.
So in order to understand that, we can
first look at the natural question, why
not just combine them using a simple
arithmetic mean as shown here?
That would be likely the most natural
way of combining them.
So what do you think?
If you want to think more, you can pause
the video.
So why is this not as good as F1?
Or what's the problem with this?
Now.
If you think about the arithmetic mean,
you can see this is the sum of multiple
terms.
In this case is a sum of precision and
recall.
In the case of a sum, the total value
tends to be dominated by the large
values.
That means if you have a very high P or
very high R, then you really don't care
about the weather.
The other value is low, so the whole
sum would be high.
Now this is not desirable because one
can easily have a perfect recall.
We can have perfect recall easily.
Can you imagine how?
It's probably very easy to imagine that
we simply retrieve all the document in
the collection.
Then we have a perfect recall.
And this will give us point of five as
the average.
But such results are clearly not very
useful for users, even though the
average using this formula would be
relatively high.
But in contrast, you can see F1
would reward the case where precision
and recall are roughly similar, so it
would penalize a case where you have
extremely high value for one of them.
So this means F1 encodes different.
tradeoffs between them.
For this example, shows actually a very
important methodology here.
When you try to solve a problem.
You might naturally think of 1
solution, let's say in this case it's
this arithmetic mean.
But it's important not to settle on
this solution.
It's important to think whether you
have other ways to combine them.
And once you think about multiple
variants, it's important to analyze
their difference.
And then think about which one makes more
sense in this case.
If you think more carefully, you will
feel that F1 probably makes more
sense than the simple arithmetic mean,
although in other cases there may be
different results, but in this case the
arithmetic mean seems not reasonable.
But if you don't pay attention to these
subtle differences, you might just take
a easy way to combine them and then go
ahead with it.
And there later you will find that
measure.
It doesn't seem to work well.
so at this methodology is actually
very important in general in solving
problem and try to think about the best
solution.
Try to understand the problem very well
and then know why you need this measure
and why you need to combine precision
and recall and then use that to guide
you in finding a good way to solve the
problem.
To summarize, we talked about
precision.
Which addresses the question.
Are the retrieval results all relevant.
We also talked about the recall.
Which addresses the question have all
the relevant documents being retrieved.
These two are the two basic measures in
text retrieval evaluation.
They are useful for many other tasks as
well.
We talked about F measure as a way
to combine precision and recall.
We also talked about the tradeoff
between precision and recall and.
This turns out to depend on the users
search tasks and will discuss this
point more in the later lecture.